mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a ladder and a cube are in a room
place the cube along the wall and then
rest the ladder along the wall so that
it is just touching the side of the cube
for precision think about the ladder as
a line segment
if the ladder has a length equal to 4
and the cube has a side length equal to
1
what is the distance between the top of
the cube and the top of the ladder
denoted by the variable y in the
following diagram
i thank nathaniel m mark l and per t for
the suggestion
for a challenge find an exact answer for
the general case where the ladder has a
length l and the cube has a side length
c
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem we have
a ladder with a length of 4
a cube with a side length equal to 1 and
we want to solve for the distance y
it seems simple but it's quite
complicated
the solution i'm going to present is
from the user blue on math stack
exchange i thought it was a very elegant
solution
we'll get started with the general case
suppose the ladder has a length of l and
the cube has a side length c
we want to solve for y in terms of l and
c
to do that let's label some more parts
of this diagram
the other side of the cube will also
have a length of c and we'll label the
horizontal distance between the ladder
and the cube as x
now we're going to do a neat little
trick
we're going to copy this diagram three
different times and construct a square
this is going to create a clever
geometric solution
we're now going to put this diagram to
the side let's connect the four corners
of these internal squares creating
another square
suppose this square has a side length
equal to w
now let's label the area of this
triangle where one side length is equal
to x as capital x
we'll label the other triangle with a
side length y as capital y
we'll label these parts in other parts
of this diagram
now suppose this triangle has an area
equal to z
by symmetry these will also have areas
equal to z
and just so we don't get lost the square
that consists of the four ladders we'll
put in blue
now let's calculate the area of this
green square
well one way to calculate its area is
that its side length is equal to w plus
c so its area will be the quantity w
plus c squared
another way is we'll sum up the areas of
the rectangles inside of this square
here we have a square with an area
that's equal to c squared
we then have two rectangles as follows
this is one rectangle and this is
another rectangle
we have two x terms and two y terms so
we have two times the quantity x plus y
and we have two z terms so we get plus
two z
we also have this square which has a
side length equal to w so its area will
be w squared
we can simplify this formula a little
bit
consider this rectangle
one half of its area will be equal to z
and one half of its area will also be
equal to x plus y
therefore x plus y is equal to z
we substitute that in into this term x
plus y and it will become two times z
we then group the z terms so we have
four times z
we now simplify this formula one more
time
we have four z plus w squared what's
that equal to it will exactly be equal
to the area of this square which has a
side length equal to l
therefore 4z plus w squared is equal to
l squared and we substitute that in
we now have a very simple formula
we take the square root of both sides
and we'll take only the positive square
root because we're considering positive
lengths
we then subtract c from both sides and
we get an equation for w in terms of the
known values of c and l
we now make one observation about w
w is exactly equal to the side length of
this square which is equal to the
quantity x plus y
so if w is equal to x plus y and we want
to solve for y
to do that we'll consider these
triangles
because the ladder has a constant slope
these two right triangles will be
similar therefore the ratio between the
horizontal leg and the vertical leg will
be equal in both triangles so we have x
over c is equal to c over y which means
x is equal to c squared over y
we substitute that into the equation
where w is equal to x plus y
we now multiply both sides of this
equation by y
and then simplify this
we now have a quadratic equation in y
we can use brahmagupta's quadratic
formula to get the following two
possible values
now we have a plus and a minus notice
the plus will be a larger term and this
will correspond to y which is the
vertical longer distance the negative
term will actually correspond to x which
is a horizontal distance so we'll
separate these two terms
we've thus figured out a general formula
for y
how does this work
in our original problem c was equal to 1
and l was equal to 4. so we substitute
that into the formula for w and we get
that w is equal to negative 1 plus the
square root of 17.
we then substitute that into our formula
for y and we get the following equation
we simplify this equation a little bit
and we get the exact answer for y this
is approximately equal to 2.76
and that's the answer to this problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you